The prophet Muhammad sallallah.aii
wasallam told us that whoever builds a
mosque for Allah, Allah will build for
him a sim at a house in Jenna. And we
know the great reward that will not only
be gained but rather will fill your
grave after your death. Whenever someone
prays there, whenever someone gives
shahada in the masid, whenever someone
learns something in the masid, yes, that
will be something that you'll have on
your scale.
[Music]
How are you guys doing? I'm here joined
with a man who needs no introduction. He
is the one and only
Yeah. Yeah. He's He is the one and only
smile to Jenna. This is the man. This is
the man who's been dominating debates
recently with the likes of David
Athetherton. Who he put in his place and
under his foot. Oh yes. And I enjoyed
watching this
man. This
man who's been attacking us as Muslim
people on Twitter and for a long time.
And you put him under your foot and in a
way that was very calculated, very
I would say very strategic. You
strangled him. I did indeed. Yes. you
strangled him. But I'll tell you what,
something which you're also very well
known for now is the politics of the
subcontinent and you've been researching
this matter for a very long time and
we've been speaking about Palestine h
for a very long time and it's very
important to speak about it because the
genocide but we don't want to do that at
the expense of forgetting about people
all over the world in India the Muslims
in India uh Muslims in Kashmir, Muslims
in other parts of the world, the
Rohingya Muslims, the Wea Muslims, the
Sudanese Muslims and all of these people
need to be mentioned as well. It's not
fair that they're not mentioned and we
have big platforms. So, we owe it to the
people to also educate them and raise
awareness on these matters. Today, we're
going to start with Kashmir. Obviously,
there was a an attack there that took
place. Tell us exactly what took place.
So the attack took place in Indian
occupied Kashmir. Yeah. So India has
occupied their part of Kashmir for quite
a while. This has been ongoing for a lot
of people don't know even before the
whole Gaza conflict as well. So this is
it's a very old um kind of issue that's
been taking place. When the Brits left
after the colonization, they left
Kashmir as no man's land. Wow. and both
jumped on it and it then got divided.
Can you see there's a trend here with
all of the a lot of the places in the
Muslim world where there's an issue. you
find some historical reasoning which
goes back to the British Empire whether
it's colonialism direct colonialism or
it's some kind of promise in the case of
the Belffor declaration that they've
left or whatever it may be but they've
they've ruined a big part of the Muslim
world before they that's that's a very
good point because a lot of um I would
say the ignorant people that have become
the far right they show a genuine
confusion as to why are these foreigners
here like what what have we done and can
can we do the same in their country? But
the these questions are inherently
flawed because of the reasons that you
said. If you look, you just need to look
Sykes Pico treaty. Sykes Pico was
literally the carving up of the Middle
East where borders were drawn literally
using a ruler to divide up countries in
which there were complex tribal and
inter kind of connection uh between
tribes that were literally separated and
borders drawn. If you look in Africa,
the Berlin conference again lines were
drawn and divided up amongst the the
Europeans.
And if you look an old picture of a
European man with a cake that says
Africa and he's cutting it up amongst
the Europeans. And similarly if you look
even with India Pakistan the lines the
borders were actually drawn again by the
British. You got the Radcliffe line the
Radcliffe line and the Durander line as
well. Fantastic examples at that as
well. I would say that subhan Allah is
something the prophet sallall wasallam
predicted and there is a very famous
hadith which um many people know but if
you don't know you should know this
hadith is exactly what you spoke about
where the prophet Muhammad wasallam said
in the
hadith that there it's almost the time
where the nations will be gathered
against you. Just like people will be
gathered in a dinner table dividing food
up basically. You see the the example
the analogy you just gave about you know
the cake being cut up. This is actually
something the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam exactly the
wording he used. It's exactly the
wording he used.
It's the people that were going to eat
food on the dinner table. And subhan
Allah as we've mentioned that's why a
lot of and this is I think an important
po point to make before we continue with
what's going on in Kashmir that when
they speak about the economic
development of these countries when they
speak about what immigration all of
these things are connected inherently to
the colonial project they want to
absolve the far right want to absolve
themselves and the alt-right and the
even the right wing from any colonial
responsibility they they don't want to
speak about that they think okay well
that's something of the part you guys
conquered things as well and and look at
how Islam spread etc and there's a huge
difference between how Islam spread
versus how they colonized countries when
Islam went to different countries they
didn't steal and then send it back to
the um for example to Mecca that's why
you'll find that the the economy of
Mecca didn't go up it was all the
economies around that were going up at
the same time whereas when the Brits
went to India
Okay. And the East Indian Company
literally from Karachi at the time
obviously was not part of Pakistan.
Pakistan was not was not a country until
1947. I think it was exactly the same
year actually ironically one year before
Israel became a country you know but you
know one one one victory you could say
and one defeat in the same year sim
similar to what happened in the 1400s
1960 in 1463 you had Constantinople
being captured but then 1490 you you had
the reconquestia sometimes that happens
you got victory and defeat happening
kind of side by side but the point I'm
making is
that you see This is it shows you it
shows you the colonial legacy. This is
something you cannot deny. You cannot
pretend it doesn't exist. The colonial
legacy is the reason why a lot of this
stuff happened. And as I was saying,
things were being transported from
Karach all the way to London. People
here were benefiting from the spices in
London and in Manchester of what was
going in Karachi. That's not happening.
That's not what happened with the
Islamic expansion. I think it's very
important to get these things right.
Islamic conquest was different to
British colonialism. And if you think
that they're the same, you're
historically inept. You don't have the
uh correct understanding. And moreover,
the worst thing is all this colonial
stuff happened after liberalism was was
uh formalized as an ideology. Mhm. You
guys are saying that, you know, you got
to be liberal, all these kind of things.
You had liberalism the time of lock and
hobbs and all that stuff and you still
had colonialism side by side with it. So
you have to start taking responsibility
for this stuff. You know, a lot of the
stuff that's happening in the world
today, I think you start having to the
right wing. You you're blaming everyone.
Immigration, you're blaming this one.
You're blaming that one. Blame
yourselves. Blame your forefathers.
Blame your grandfathers. Blame your
great-grandfathers that had people
shackled in chains, that had people as
slaves, that were racists, that went to
our countries, that settled in our
countries for for hundreds of years,
that drew lines, that did that that
stole our resources. Do you think the
chickens are not going to come home to
roost after all of what you've done?
Yeah. because this Kashmir situation is
as as we've mentioned with many of the
conflicts of today as a direct result of
the colonial legacy of the British
Empire. But to continue now, what
happened specifically
uh with this attack? So there was an
attack that took place in Indian
occupied Kashmir that took the lives of
about 26 people. Yeah. Which is of
course tragic and um any life that's
taken it's terrible. We mourn the loss
and you know terrorism, extremism,
whatever you call it, has no religion.
But that being said, there's a lot of
question marks surrounding the
circumstances
um around this attack. One being that
this was in a place that there is
significant amount of military and
police. However, it took them 1 and 1/2
hours to reach there. Um, so it was
actually ironically even though the
Kashmiris are now being attacked by the
Hindutva and the Hindu extremists.
However, in the first one and a half
hours, it was the Kashmiris that were
picking up these people, putting them on
horseback cuz that's the only way to get
to that place by foot or by horseback.
They were the ones that were tending to
them. And ironically, one of the person
that was killed was also a Muslim. His
name is Sayyed Adil Hussein. And this
individual actually tried to stop the
the attacker and he died. Yeah. And he
died in the process. He gave his life
for this country that is now demonizing
Kashmiris and Muslims as a result. But
not only was that ironic but the
Pakistani media which we need to give
both sides of the coin. We can't just be
giving the Indian side of the story. The
other side of the story is Pakistan has
looked at the FIR which is the police
report the first incident report and
they noticed that I think it was uh 6
kilometers away from the uh where the
attack took place the police
station filed the report the report was
filed 10 minutes after the attack. 10
minutes bro. It's firstly it's 6 kmh far
away from the attack and then it takes
them 10 minutes after the attack and
they've drawn up this document and in
there they've said many many times a
foreign interference re really so the
Pakistani news are saying this is very
dubious this is indicative of a false
flag attack and that's what a AI digital
and all of these platforms are saying
it's a false flag attack it's not
indicative it doesn't make sense that a
highly militarized area on top of that
the way the FIR has been conducted and
done um and the strategic nature of
everything because the first thing Modi
did was not check about the security
failure not check about you know why you
know things weren't conducted properly
and what actually happened you know what
he did he cut off a treaty it's called
the Indis water treaty which was done in
1960 which literally means that there
are rivers, there's water coming in from
India and there was a treaty in which
there was mutual they said they can't um
they can't block access, right? Indians
cannot block block access. Well, they've
said that you know what we we we have
revoked the treaty. We've paused the
treaty. Different people are using
different terms. Some people are saying
India has cut off water to Pakistan. Um
that's that's part of a a greater treaty
of peace between the two countries,
isn't it? Exactly. So, is this your cut
off a little bit? Just come. Oh sorry.
Yeah. Could could someone argue that
this is kind of like they're edging
towards war here? No. Pakistan have
clearly said that if this is carried out
and if it's done the India is declaring
war on us. So we will declare war on
them. So it's an act of war. Those are
the exact words. This is an act of war
if this happens because it will lead to
starvation. I mean that's why you've got
even the Guardian article of them
speaking to farmers. I mean without
water uh without even information of
water there could be floods without and
restriction of water because of
dams agriculture is affected the whole
country can be brought to their knees.
This is a very strategic ex uh advantage
that India wanted for quite a while.
Yeah. In the last I think two or three
interactions between the two countries
this has not happened. It's only
happened very recently and this is if
something was to happen in the future,
it doesn't make sense for India to do
anything now. It's just it's illogical.
So they're going to take this W. This is
a victory for them. Yeah. Why? Because
it's completely what you're doing. When
you have control over the resources of a
country, you've got them by the
proverbial balls. Let's be honest. Yeah.
Um sorry for the example. Uh but if
you've got them strategically anytime
you want to attack them now, that's it.
They're going to be easily manipulated,
easily kind of uh defeated. Let's be
honest, water is essential, bro. You
cannot go 4 days without water. And if
most of the water is coming from India
and India saying, "We're not going to
tell you about floods. We can build
dams. We can restrict the water and all
of this." And when you've got these uh
protests taking place, what are the
Indians doing? They're holding up water
bottles and saying, "Hey, look." Mocking
like collective punishment. Where have
you heard this before? People mocking
collective punishment. Where have you
heard this? Where have you heard this?
Of Yeah. And guess who the closest
friend of Indian Well, India and Modi is
Benjamin Netanyahu and Israel. They're
actually helping they're helping India
with this plan because India wants to be
an ethno state just like Israel. And
they're both saying, "Look, we only have
one country and look, we've got the same
enemy, the Muslims, and look again, you
know, it's our land and our land is
being taken over." They use the same
talking points. They use the same drama.
They use the same sort of control. India
is very low down even in press freedom.
Yeah, it's a country with immense amount
of potential. However, it's being given
into the hands of Hindu extremists that
are literally curtailing the progress of
this country and we want India to
succeed. There are many many Muslims.
There's a great deal of Muslims in that
country. However, the trajectory that
it's taking, it's not a good trajectory,
bro. And that's why there's current
tensions between the two countries.
There's border skirmishes that took
place. India's claim to kill Pakistani
soldiers. Pakistan sending tanks.
Personally, I don't think war's going to
take place. However, these are
precautionary measures. India's got what
it needed. It'll probably just dial it
down as much as they could, but the
typical things have happened like
closing of airspace, expelling, you
know, you know, not allowing visas from
each other's countries and the likes.
But, ironically, Pakistan has revoked
the visas of the Indians and sent them
back as has India. But Pakistan has not
included the seikhs in this. the Sikhs
are exempt because Sikhs find you know a
great deal of uh kind of connection with
Pakistan as well and they've got their
leaders telling them don't fight. I mean
the the religion was founded in
Pakistan, wasn't it?
So there you have it like um they they
see because they want an independent
state called Kalistan as well and India
has really been killing their seniors
and superiors whether it's in Canada and
interfering wherever they can. So the
Sikhs understand this and they know and
just to just to maybe the last question
I want to ask here is the plight of the
um oppressed Kashmiris under this
occupation. What can you say uh of this
particularly of of our brothers and
sisters many of which leave comments
sometimes give us send us emails they
want us to kind of speak about their
struggles. The thing is bro we saw it
the last time we spoke about Kashmir and
what was going on with again it was a
law that was passed that was further um
oppressing the the Kashmiris there.
They they switch off the uh internet.
They they switch off this that's the
connection to the world in the in the mo
in the modern age. Imagine cutting off
internet that you cannot even document
your plight and put it on social media.
That's the control like switching off
electricity having military presence
there bulldozing houses. Uh Kashmiri
students are being attacked attacked on
the street inside dragged out beaten
lynched. This is something which is for
people that follow the what goes on in
India, it's pretty normal. Yeah. And the
Hindu extremism is rising and ext and
increasing to such a degree that there
was a protest outside the Pakistani
embassy a couple of days ago. And were
they peaceful? You know, were they doing
yoga and were they preaching a himsa of
Mahatma Gandhi? No, they weren't, bro.
Two there were two arrests. There were
two arrests and one uh there was a third
arrest. Where is this? This outside the
Pakistani embassy here in London. Oh my
god. Two arrests of these Indian
extremists. And the third arrest was
somebody who um smashed the windows of
We don't hear about this stuff. How
come? Yeah, that's because it's uh I
mean who was the previous uh prime
minister of this country? Do you want to
give me his Who? Which one? There's so
many of them. Who who came before the
one that Oh, Rishiak. Oh, what was his
uh what was his ethnicity?
Was he Indian? He was Indian. The home
secretary that that large
uh Priy Priy Patel. Yeah, Priy Patel.
You know what I mean? So the Indians are
very influential in this country. A lot
of people are saying Rishi Sunnak under
his time a lot of Indians were allowed
to come in. In fact, if you look at the
immigration figures, the top few
countries, India is definitely at the
top, Indian, Nigerians, etc., but
Indians are definitely there and uh
that's that's the unfortunate reality
that India just like it's it's a growing
economy and a growing country that again
will be like Israel very difficult for
countries to go against them. And just
like when the Kashmir thing was
happening last time, what did our
countries do? Modi was invited to the
UAE and given a golden medal. I mean,
it's just we're just seeing the same
stuff happen. That's why when stuff
happens the first time, we should knock
it on the head because you know what I
mean? Like it just it just continues. It
grows. No, it does. Yeah, it does. No,
you've made such fascinating points here
and I think people are going to be
watching taking copious notes if not at
least taking mental ones. Um, and you've
you've been an encyclopedia of knowledge
today. Thank you, brother. with with
this with this particular edifying
information. With that we will
conclude. Hey you are you wasting your
time on social media again? Your
brothers and sisters in Islam net from
Norway are establishing a masid a da
center establishing a masid to convey
the message of Islam is one of the best
deeds a Muslim can do. There's a huge
need for it in Norway. You know this and
I know this. So that makes the reward
even greater. So give generously and
Allah asawel will give you even more.